thank you
[Music]
this morning on the dish the Big Texas
cookbook
Texas monthly magazine has been putting
out recipes for 50 years but they've
never done a cookbook until now it's a
combination of western cowboy Southern
Cuisine Mexican and a whole lot more as
we discovered with a trip to a truck
before we tackled the table
okay we're making the saw the Special
Sauce yeah so this is called Jose it
goes with just about everything we even
dip our crawfish cells in there too you
might not expect the Texas dish to begin
in a Southeast Asian food truck
but Texas it seems is big enough to
accommodate just about any pallet I mean
this is as fresh as fresh sauce
and I'll let you finish it off the Joe
some spicy and sour sauce that Bob Sam
Smith pounds down to go with his
award-winning ribeye steak skewers is
just one of the many recipes featured in
The Big Texas cookbook so this is uh use
your hand kind of food all right you
wouldn't normally think you'd get rib
eye out of a food truck right because
but ribeye rib eye has always been sort
of a special meat occasion thing here
it's it's not we're not in Texas right
yeah joining us at Sam Smith's truck Pat
sharp and Courtney Bond who've been
writing about food at Texas monthly for
a combined 75 years and are two of the
driving forces behind the Magazine's
food coverage
the Big Texas cookbook features
everything from smoked turkey to
Jalapeno Dove poppers to buttermilk
fried chicken liver and caramelized
onion po boys
just to start you say in the opening
Texas cooking is more eclectic and
braided than people think what does that
mean
it's just so much more vibrant and
varied than I think people realize
sometimes you know you say braided I
think I love that word by the way I know
I love that word and I'm looking at
those kolaches with Frito pie right and
corn chips on top and I'm thinking that
is that's a brand new recipe because
that comes from the Czech tradition and
then also from the Mexican Tex-Mex and
fabulous junk food tradition and they're
all ready together the Texas Czech
kolaches can be done with fruits or meat
that is Fusion Cuisine yes absolutely
some people don't like the word a lot of
people don't like the word Fusion all
they need to get over it I mean is there
is there a better word up next was a
chili dish
uh leotians spin on a classic Texas
staple what am I tasting in there that
I'm like a little bit surprised at
that's really good it's got some there's
some fish sauce is that maybe what it is
yeah Ginger wow Ginger there's a lot
going on there there is a lot going on
fish sauce lemongrass cayenne pepper and
gollingal
but not beans I don't mean to step into
dangerous territory but beans and chili
I knew you were gonna say beans
oh God
why does everybody bring that up
you were like do not put beans in your
chili in the book yeah we think that
tradition comes from the competition
Chile competitions are a big thing in
Texas they used to be even bigger and
the rules really concentrate on the meat
in other words they don't want any beans
in there diluting the flavors they just
want to be able to judge the quality of
the meat beans were a distraction you
know they were considered filler we then
moved to enchiladas replacing the spoon
with a fork
all right I'm gonna eat it with a big
fork is that okay
I think you should listen it's Big Texas
bigger in Texas
okay I do like this Fork though it'd be
more fun I want this on all dish
segments right now it's much more fun
it's much more fun with the big Port but
go ahead now that's very healthy too
it's hearty and excellent
yeah right yeah for a long time we've
like suffered through commodity style
tortillas you know Mass manufactured and
when you actually have one now it's
becoming the norm for taco joints to
make their own tortillas and that's
that's a big deal and it and it does
make all the difference for desserts
there was a Texas sheet cake a recipe
from Courtney Bond's grandmother
featuring pecans we didn't talk about
pecans but they also play a big role in
the book yes yes they're everywhere yeah
it's uh the pecan is our state tree it
the nut is our state nut we love them in
pralines we love them in pecan pie of
course we've got what at least three
recipes in the cookbook yeah that
involve pecans the drink a Mexican
martini with a nejo tequila the lime
juice and orange liqueur
feel free to bookmark these recipes now
because if you check back in a few years
all the new influences will likely mean
the Big Texas cookbook will have even
more big changes cheers okay thank you
to the Mexican Martini to Big Texas to
Big Texas
to Big Texas here it was something that
I tell you those enchiladas that's maybe
the best tortillas I ever had
in search of the best enchilada I I just
they're awesome they're my favorite food
I mean just look at some of the
everything looks so I have copies of the
Big Texas cookbook for you guys but
check out some of these oh my God look
at the look at that blackberry cobbler
with the pigs here so much of that
looked amazing it really did they got a
chicken fried steak gravy recipe that I
think I want to make like wow I have we
had a great idea I hope you heard that
Jeff's Cooking
set it